hi everyone welcome to our July meet up
event I'm Patricia Schuster one of the
co-organizers together with Shawn law
and Ben's Island who's in the back
today is our lightning talk event which
everyone has been looking forward we
have four speakers today who will each
share a short presentation on their work
or something interesting in the field of
data science so we just have a few
things to go through first first we
always like to acknowledge our sponsors
so numb focus sponsors our meetup group
participation TD Ameritrade provides the
space for us to meet in and - we have
some - representatives here today and -
sponsors our dinner for these events if
you're affiliated with - you want to
give a little get a look at a little
wave great lots of - people here today
we're always looking for feedback so
this is our Twitter and our email
address if you want to provide feedback
there or just directly to one of the
organizers throughout the evening
so a few points emergency exits we have
a staircase here please don't use the
elevators in case of emergency as I
mentioned provide feedback to us
directly or through any of our accounts
and also this is a borrowed space so
please clean up after yourself before
you leave so for Q&A just a few
guidelines so unless your question is
quick hold it until the end of the
presentation that's especially important
today since we have four presentations
please phrase your question in the form
of a question and keep your questions -
30 seconds or less avoid long statements
and monologues and also remember that
there will be open time for discussions
at the end of the entire event you can
come up and find whichever speaker you
want to talk to you directly okay now
I'll read our code of conduct pi data is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race religion or level of experience we
do not tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds and levels
of experience sexual language and
imagery is not appropriate for any of
our meet-up events
be kind to others do not insult or
put-down other attendees behave
professionally remember that harassment
and sexist racist or exclusionary jokes
are not appropriate for pi data
attendees violating these rules will may
be asked to leave the meetup at the sole
discretion of the meetup organizers
thank you all for helping make this a
welcome welcoming and friendly event for
all so we like to do a quick icebreaker
so that you can meet the people around
you the topic this month comes from Sean
and it is which do you like better water
parks or theme parks so I come to a
decision
[Music]
that was it good okay um so can we get
hands for theme park and waterpark and
it depends on the weather I like that
answer okay great okay so we always do
had this month in data science and this
time we want to mention that there was
recently an international summer school
on deep learning and it was hosted by
two people who are local san arbor dance
the three people there were three hosts
oh I'm sorry they were invited speakers
two of whom were local people from Ann
Arbor Dan and Alexander and then also oh
hello and also Sebastian you might
recognize that name because he's been
one of our speakers in the past and was
it a good event do you enjoy it okay
excellent good our next event will be
August 14th our speakers Jack Jacqueline
Nola's and her topic will be when data
science projects fail I think we can all
relate to that so she will she will have
the the answer to rescue us for when our
projects fail oh and what the are
usergroup okay so now we have some time
for community announcements if any of
you want to mention an event that's
coming up or if you're looking for
someone to join your group you have a
job opening or if you're new on the job
market and you want to maybe mention
that to everyone does anyone have
anything they want to share okay Buster
I work on the research and data science
team at interactions which is here in
Ann Arbor we're looking for someone with
experience in NLP we generally use a lot
of Python and keep learning but general
experience or knowledge of design
great one so my name is Kara Everett I
work for a language learning company a
company in Farmington Hills so we're
looking for a data scientist though if
any of your
or you can check out our website some
angle languages I couldn't clean it my
name is Clayton I'm the first day of
scientists at ever active which is a
start-up here in town and we do like
industrial sensor monitoring and
detection the automated detection of
equipment failure I'm looking for a
second data scientist to help me build
out the team do a lot more hiring in the
future and also make sort of high-level
decisions about how we work and what
tools we use and things like that
we're a Python and our shop gets equal
all that kind of stuff so come chat with
me if that sounds interesting
very nice yeah my name is fine from the
bottom it's a Vitamix in the original
Michigan and we are looking at two high
social really an expert in JavaScript
Google cloud so to do analyze it for
single islands great
you have jobs the job openings menu and
it just you know grandma card or
whatever we're having fun into the
website it's a house
excellent Trisha I work with Kristen has
the Michigan Institute for data science
this is not a job announcement but I
just want to put a feeler out I know
that this is the muppet ask me
a way for students to partner with and
design so if that's
yes for that so if you want to hide it
one of us on either side of the
mentorship if you want to be a mentor if
your student who's looking for a mentor
talk to us any others Paige
like climate modeling and
ocean-atmosphere interaction so I don't
know a whole lot about the data science
bro specifically
so I'm kind of here to learn about data
science
so how various
excellent Wow lots of job openings it's
great news okay alright so now I'm gonna
introduce our four speakers now at the
beginning our first speaker is Brittany
Wilson who will be speaking on wrapping
up a master's in data science our second
speaker is Ashley Payne on data in earth
science and atmospheric rivers our third
speaker is Rose putler the ABCs of
career confidence and our fourth
speakers Laura Burdick lessons from
multilingual data so let's welcome all
of these speakers okay so I'm working on
a master's in data science my bachelor's
is in Business Administration having a
conversation with a friend she was like
you should diversify so it's kind of how
I ended up here I use a multi criteria
decision making model to kind of you
know is this what I want to do with my
life should I do something else
decision-making process okay so I guess
I kind of I wanted to learn more about
programming I worked with C++ in high
school which is kind of like maybe I
should refresh on that a little bit more
so that they were really working with it
too much and then I guess the decision
to go for a master's in data science or
just the Masters and general is access
to resources so access to teachers but
also online libraries you can get a lot
of good books that can teach you more
outside of class so I guess I'm gonna do
a quick overview of projects there are
so if anyone's interested in machine
Lodhi machine learning this is all done
in are so I did a few different so
there's some classifiers on here so
there's a reinforcement learning example
and this is all you can just basically
plug it in for the most part if you know
how to program in are let's see so then
there are some data engineering classes
involved with it I was considering doing
the specialization but
it just didn't fit in with my timeframe
but I'm still taking so I'm gonna take
data wrangling class coming up and then
still staying on the data science track
I'm doing my next course is gonna be in
deep learning and then I have my
practicum is coming up so I'll be done
in April
it took me basically so I think I
started January 2018 I also work as a
field researcher for you Mitch my
schedule is kind of flexible but at 35
hours a week mixing it in with this kind
of slowed me down a bit but I don't know
anyways I enjoy both things let's see so
where I am now is essentially I'm
deciding on okay so maybe I should talk
about so this is some of the stuff I've
done with Hadoop this is a MapReduce
project a basic recommender system I'll
show my website if anyone wants to check
it out a little bit more later I'll show
you the link and how to get in contact
with me so I work with vagrant and
borrow so building out nodes my sequel
connector anaconda installed on to these
and then deploying them and so there's
some projects with HBase and then you
made an inverted index with Jupiter
notebook and PI spark and then working
with sandbox I need to build out my kit
I haven't really been doing that and
it's coming kind of behind on that um C
and then some Python projects this the
Masters that I'm in is not heavy on
Python in the way that I would like it
to be for data science the data
wrangling class is more so but so
sentiment analysis with Twitter we just
basically use their API and then text
analysis integer programming there's
some other stuff yeah I don't know yeah
so now I'm basically deciding on what
I'm going to focus on if I'm gonna go
more towards deep learning reinforcement
learning or stick with machine learning
or just be more broads
bactrim with artificial intelligence and
then also do I want to focus on sensors
embedded systems are in the human
human-in-the-loop research and I don't
know studies are like questions or
something it's obvious I'm not really a
public speaker you know and then I guess
some of this stuff if you guys are
really heavy our coders have mercy on me
I'm probably gonna look back and be like
oh my gosh that was a horrible horrible
I don't know a mistake that I made in
that project or something but I think
it's my teacher gave me a good grade so
hey I guess I'll count on that okay
all right do any questions later looking
now that you're in the midst of this
program do you have any lessons learned
or advice for students who are starting
a masters again yes
hardware is very important so I have
this 2011 MacBook that I dropped a you
know terabyte solid-state drive in
upgraded by Ram it's like yes okay I'm
ready for this and then it has an i5 CPU
and that just like and so I ended up
getting better you know desktop system
so I guess yeah hardware is a big big
thing especially if you're doing if
you're building out clusters if you're
building out nodes with how do but
that's going to take a lot
mm-hmm um so yeah that's what I'm kind
of like I'm trying to narrow I guess
it's kind of it's really broad and I'm
trying to narrow in more I'm actually
taking a class right now where I have to
do you know research on a particular
problem and I'm in the I guess the midst
of developing developing that now and
hopefully that will lead to kind of more
of a focused trajectory mm-hmm oh okay
so ways you can get in contact with me
so this is my website
that's my LinkedIn phone number email
address
I just was curious how your um your
colony I think
doing some site work or something like
that um so I'm a field researcher for
the University of Michigan I'm in the
production role it's basically like data
collection it's not it's not really data
science I'm not you know doing any sort
of analysis of the data I'm just making
sure it's nice and pretty for the most
part yes
yeah that's my personal website it's
also my way of like kind of tracking the
work that I've done so far cuz it's kind
of its easy to get
I don't know lost in the shuffle oh
thank you yeah I have to like limit the
amount of time I spend on it like oh I
like that color maybe this one and it's
like that's meaningless just color okay
hello and so I am coming at this
lightening talk as a data user more so
than a trained and true data scientist
though I think I've become one over the
years so I'm an assistant professor in
climate and space sciences and
engineering so up in the College of
Engineering and I actually started with
my bachelor's in geosciences so I was in
caves collecting Gipp water and looking
at Paleo climate applications but I did
my PhD at a university California Irvine
essentially in data science or data
science I wish atmospheric science so
that's actually where I learned how to
program and so starting with MATLAB and
now I primarily use Python for a lot of
my work and and you know I think the
thing I want you to get away from this
is the sheer amount of data available so
this is a satellite image from
geostationary satellite showing earth
and so I wanted to start with what does
earth science data actually look like
so this is going to be focused on the
the atmosphere more so than the ocean
sorry for the oceanographer so you know
let's just start with observations so
you have wood can't walk too far and you
have satellite imagery so we have this
geostationary satellite goes east Cygnus
is a the cyclone global navigation
satellite system so this is actually
something that is connected with my
department so Chris ruff if anyone knows
that is a P I on this project and then
you can also have field campaigns so
this c-130 atmospheric River for khana
reconnaissance projects so this is more
applied to what I actually look like or
look look at sorry and I wish I could be
a part of this because it looks really
cool but I know the people in charge of
this project and so they they basically
fly these airplanes and transect this
atmospheric feature and drop basically
instruments out of the back of this
airplane and measure the vertical
profile of the atmosphere and then you
also have basically data that comes from
an observational station that you know
is kind of in place and so this is one
example from the middle of Oklahoma and
the atmospheric radiation measurement
facility and this is actually data that
I use for model evaluation as I'll show
you later and so that's all the the kind
of observations so what you see in the
top left corner is a snapshot of all the
observations that one particular data
assimilation model takes to create a
kind of a gridded product for
people like me to use and it's not very
visible right now but basically this
this map is covered in dots and so each
of those dots represents a different
type of observation so these vary in
basically the time step between each
observation they vary in the spatial
resolution so data assimilation is
actually a field in itself not one that
I'm very familiar with so hold off on
the questions there but what happens is
you basically you can take observations
raw observations or processed
observations and put them into a model
and basically get modeled data and so
there's a number of things that kind of
builds up these models and at the most
fundamental level you start with kind of
these governing equations so momentum
equations conservation so and so forth
but there's a number of things that can
introduce uncertainty so you know the
resolution we're talking about spacial
temporal resolution the domain are you
looking at a global scale or using a
global scale model or are you looking at
say for example Texas and that's it
initial and boundary conditions so how
do you actually start the model running
okay so there there's another source of
uncertainty parameterizations I'll talk
about in the next slide a little bit
more but these are basically things that
we can use to estimate things that are
happening below the the grid grid scale
and then finally numerical approximation
so you need to do some rounding
somewhere that's a very broad way of
saying that and then you get these very
nice figures like one I made and I'll
talk about this feature in a little a
little bit more later this is a really
nice schematic showing what actually
goes into a general circulation model so
you can see you have
basically grids covering the earth and
then you also have vertical levels so in
the atmospheric sciences
sciences we usually think about vertical
levels in terms of pressure but the
model might not actually use that so the
grid scale defines the resolution the
model smaller the grid cells the more
detail in the model but then that's
where you run into computational
limitations so I can't run models on
this computer I actually have to use a
supercomputer which happens to be
located in Wisconsin and sometimes
crashes which is not great and so you
can see within these grid cells the
typical size is around 100 kilometers
there's a number of processes that are
basically estimated within these grid
cells so yes so getting into what I do
and this is a very brief snapshot of a
small portion of my research so one of
the things that I focus on is model
evaluation so there are these features
that are not well captured in GCN's
because of essentially their generation
mechanisms so they start at you know
basically thunderstorm scales so very
small and then they bloom up to these
massive basically state size storms
sometimes if you're looking at a smaller
state and so these are mesoscale
convective systems they are responsible
for up to 70% at some time rainfall or
the Great Plain and so essentially to
model these you need to get to very high
spatial resolutions and to start to get
at resolving potentially some of the
convection within this within the model
now you run into computational
limitations so while we wait for the
computer sciences to catch up this is
kind of the the cutting edge for GCM
so variable resolution models so we have
a uniform grid and what we're doing is
we're comparing that to a grid that is
refined over a certain region and so the
questions here are how well do variable
resolution models actually capture these
multi scale features and then what is
the effect of these parameters ations of
the estimations in the development of
these features and so I have some work
on this but because of time I'm going to
skip to the next and so that the other
thing that I'm very focused on and is
consuming a lot of time is actually
feature detection so I am very
interested in how atmospheric rivers you
know what modifies their behavior at the
large scale so large-scale circulation
how does that modify these very sorry
narrow pathways of intense horizontal
moisture transport in the lower
atmosphere should it defined it and so
I've circled what that looks like in my
nice little globe that I applauded up
there and these are really important
because they are tied to a lot of
flooding events mudslides oh no one
minute and flooding mudslides and the
like around the world but mostly in
California and they're also essential to
water resources so the definition right
now is largely qualitative so you look
at this and like oh that's an
atmospheric River that so that's
basically led to a lot of quantitative
ways of looking at these at the climate
scale so beyond the event by event basis
some questions here but I wanted to
leave you with this this is showing the
diversity of algorithms to actually
identify these features there are a lot
there and so I am a lead author on a
intercomparison project to start to
quantify the uncertainty in the choice
of algorithm in atmospheric river
science and
and this is just showing a single
atmospheric River and all of these
different algorithms identifying some
portion of this feature
so what precipitation is associated with
these features how are they going to
respond in the changing climate so and
so forth these are questions that were
interested in so thanks they're
transient so they move and that that's
one of the difficulties about detecting
them yep so they occur much lower in the
atmosphere than jet streams but yet you
can think of them as yeah corridors of
of high winds in the lower atmosphere so
hi everyone my name is rose petal er
today I'll be talking about the ABCs of
career confidence which is while I am a
data scientist this is sort of
tangential to that um and since I don't
have that much time it's really going to
be the abbreviated ABCs of career
confidence so a little bit about me so I
have a couple of different degrees in
statistics so an undergrad in BA and
statistics and a master's in bio stats I
have what I think is some respectable
job experience managing projects
managing people working at the Medical
School I currently work at Thermo Fisher
Scientific and I will not talk about
that at all but if you questions about
it later feel free to come talk to me
but I'm now sort of a biome formatic
scientist yet I still don't feel that
comfortable calling myself a
statistician or an expert in any way
sometimes so you may be sort of
wondering why I'm oh my gosh my slide
show
why I'm talking about career confidence
so do I have confidence in my career all
the time no I don't and the confidence I
do have I feel like is hard one but
based on some conversations I've had
recently with students and folks who are
looking for jobs or who are
transitioning careers I think that I
have some insight and I want to share
that insight with you so I'm going to
talk about the abridge ABCDEF I'm not
getting any further than that ABCs of
career confidence so a advocate for
yourself so one of the things that I
think I have realized over time is that
you shouldn't assume that anyone knows
what you're doing you are your biggest
champion and no one's gonna sort of know
what you've been up to or why you're
awesome or why you're invaluable unless
you really sort of talk about it and
bring it up and the first step to doing
that is really tracking it so something
that I do is once a month I try to wrack
my brain and say what cool thing did I
do this month even if I can't really
come up with anything that feels
important I try to track it because that
way I can look back in six months and be
like oh yeah I did that cool thing so
things I think about what ways have you
been awesome recently what is it that
you want from your career where what's
your trajectory
tell your boss tell your friends tell
your co-workers and track it but no one
else is going to do it for you
necessarily so it's scary but it's
important be be everywhere so
congratulations first step you're here
you made it you're networking you're
doing things and that's really I think
important so go network go talk to
people your co-workers other people even
if it seems lame even if you're not sure
you should go if you don't belong even
if you're the intern or the student you
should go you should meet people you
should be networking over time you will
really start to feel more confident and
start to feel like
oh wait I actually belong here people
want me here I am contributing see now
this one's gonna make everyone upset
cover letters matter and I'm sorry I
hate cover letters
you hate cover letters we all hate cover
letters but I would argue that they're
not just important for the job the job
you want the job you're applying for
they're more important for you so what
you're doing is you're giving yourself
the time and the space to sit back and
say what do I like about this what do I
like about what I'm doing now what I'm
doing in the future they allow you to
sort of sit back think about what you
want and then actually express it which
are two very different things especially
when you're like in the midst of
applying to 18 jobs and you hate them
all and you just want a job so give
yourself the time and space to really
write a new cover letter understanding
is vain sort of how you fit and why you
like it will help you stand out not just
in that cover letter and get you the
interview but then in the interview
you'll actually be able to say hey I
know why I want this job and articulate
that so and this is another thing you'll
hate don't recycle cover letters really
don't do it deep a little bit different
doubt others but not in a mean way so
what I mean with this is you may think
you don't know what you're talking about
and that guy does they don't I promise
everyone is faking it not everyone knows
what they're talking about at least not
all the time and by doubting nicely
being skeptical paying attention asking
questions you may catch something that
other people didn't think of you may
have that insight that out-of-the-box
thinking where you can say hey what
about this thing and if worse comes to
worse you will get credit for asking the
question
for paying attention and really you have
nothing to lose to just make sure you're
sort of doubting which sounds I mean we
like our co-workers right we we think
they're smart people but
doubt them in a nice way so II elevator
story now I hate the concept of an
elevator story I think it's like very
strange like why am I talking to someone
in the elevator
why am I telling them about what I'm
doing why do they care I just want to
get off on my floor so I think there's a
couple better ways to to think about
this and I'm going to go over one of
them in detail and I took out one of my
other slides but that's fine so the
first way to think about it the only way
I will talk in depth about right now
think of someone you love who loves you
unconditionally but it has absolutely no
idea what you do doesn't know had
absolutely not they're not in the field
they have very different skills so
rather than an elevator story and I have
permission for this one I'm gonna call
this an Eric story so this is my fiancee
Eric he's wonderful he's great he has a
degree in philosophy and thinks that
what I do at work every day is sort of
like bloop blop bloop he has no idea
what I do at all and so if I want to
simplify what I do
if I want to think about how I talk
about what I do every day or in an
abstract way I think about how would I
explain to Eric or sub in another person
how would I explain to them how would I
simplify it how would I sort of take its
parts and and explain it simply so I
sort of try it out on him or just
pretend that I'm talking to him
so how would you describe your interests
or your job just someone who wouldn't
judge you so you shouldn't have sort of
that fear you should have the confidence
when talking about it but has no idea
what you're doing because I think it's
easy for us to say well everyone knows
that I'm what I'm doing is not that
special but it is it really is you do
know things that was another option for
D and then if you're trying to sort of
talk to other people
I lost the elevator story they're sort
of just think about how can you talk
about your jobs your interests and sort
of frame it in a way that helps you feel
confident if it helps to think about
someone a little more technical you can
sort of build off that simple simple
story to start with so last but not
least F forge ahead you won't always
feel confident month by month week by
week second by second you may have high
and low times sometimes you'll feel
really bad so my other F feel your
feelings so try to understand why you're
feeling the way you're feeling in a
professional setting even so in my last
three years I've worked at three
different jobs and each time I've
enjoyed it more because I really took
the time just understand why I'm feeling
the way I'm feeling from a positive and
a negative standpoint this will allow
you to actually make that next step move
forward with confidence so listen to
your feelings whether in the current job
and the future one but generally this
will allow you to sort of build
resilience become more confident and
move forward in your career and in your
work so thank you
these are my ABCDEF of career coveted
tangential data science but I can also
talk about what I do at some other time
afterwards so thanks
[Applause]
so for the elevator story do you
recommend that you never use jargon even
if you're like at a professional
conference I think that's I think that's
fine I think I think I sort of try to
feel it out so one of my other things
one of my side that I didn't include is
a friend of my name Eve I know a lot of
people with names who has like a
technical she is a PhD in a technical
field and I'm always trying to impress
her a little bit and so part of that is
thinking about okay you start at that
simple story and then you say okay how
do I sort of talk about it in a way that
sort of ups the technical factor ups the
jargony factor especially if you're
gonna like a conference setting and
you're like want to impress this guy you
know like sort of thinking about it in
those two different ways sort of helps
me has helped me sort of crystallize and
then embellish opponent if that makes
sense so I think jargon is fine but in
in the right time in place I mean for me
it has involved and I didn't mention
this during the cover letter stuff but
when you're when you're sort of thinking
about and talking about sort of bringing
in outside voices who are not in the
same area and part of that might be
meeting someone here and saying like oh
hey you know I'm interested in what you
do or it sounds like you have an
interesting experience and having that
conversation I think sort of getting to
both questions in some way like as
you're writing cover letters or talking
about what you're doing sort of having
outside editors on some level right can
help you both network with someone who's
outside your field or outside I could
email or outside something but also give
you some some clarity so you're not just
sort of like stuck in the jargon or
stuck in the I don't know that headspace
that everyone everyone knows what I know
that's I don't have anything
thing to say so I don't know if that
answers their question but hi my name is
Laura
Berdych I am a PhD student in computer
science and engineering at the
University of Michigan I just finished
my fourth year in my PhD and I'm going
to talk to you a little bit about some
of what I've been working on recently in
multilingual data so to start I should
explain that I do research in natural
language processing so lesson number one
is thinking about what is a word in
different languages and this was
something that I was not expecting
necessarily I probably should have been
but I wasn't and so this was something I
learned so this is a sign in three
different languages the English
translation is on the top here and then
we have Romanian Hungarian German and so
this is just some administrative sign
what's really interesting in here though
and what I want to draw your attention
to is how many words each sign uses so
the sign says the exact same thing in
all of these different language but note
that Hungarian is able to say this exact
same thing in five words whereas English
the English translation takes fourteen
words to say the same thing that's a
pretty huge difference for a small sign
and so this is clearly indicating that
the idea of a word is changing language
to language some things are certainly
the same but the amount of meaning that
a word is capturing is certainly
changing across languages as
demonstrated here so here's another
example I hope you can read this
basically this is um Turkish words here
on the left and they're English
translations on the right and you can
see Turkish is what's called an
agglutinative language and so this means
you can basically make words by taking
tiny units of meeting and stringing them
together and so you have this ability to
create very very long words with very
specific meanings and we don't do this
nearly as much in English I mean you do
you'll find a couple of examples you
know but
not nearly as much and so you have but
you kind of have that ability in Turkish
all right so bringing this back to kind
of data science and data analysis what
are you supposed to do with this if you
want to work with multiple languages but
you have this disconnected words are
different in different languages and you
can't compare them apples to apples
necessarily so here's our example if we
have the clause watching the runner go
by I would say there's kind of three
three different options you can work
with things at a word level recognizing
that like at a word level the words mean
different things but still I think
sometimes it makes sense to work with
them at a word level you can go to like
the most granular level and think about
things at a character level I would say
the caveat with this is that not all
languages are written in a Latin script
the same way English's and so the set of
characters is not even going to be the
same across languages there's also kind
of an intriguing middle option which i
think is cool and that's like the sub
word level so somewhere in between the
word level and the character level so
maybe you take like the word watching
and you break it down into like watch
and and those kind of have some meaning
in themselves like the root and the
suffix and there are like different here
a couple citations for like things you
can do is sub word units there are lots
of other methods you can do with sub
word units so which of these are you
supposed to use I would say the answer
is it really depends on what you're
trying to do but it's something that you
have to really be aware of and think
about when you're working with
multilingual data okay lesson one was on
word variation lesson two is on language
variation and this in some sense is an
is an extension of lesson one
so if lesson one is that words are gonna
vary dramatically language to language
let's go one step farther and I will
just say languages vary dramatically on
pretty much every parameter that you can
think of and so when you're working with
multilingual data this is going to
really affect your analysis so there's a
couple of websites that are really nice
for gaining insight into this I'm not
going to talk too much about it because
it's a it's like a whole field of study
in and of its
but I'll just throw these out ethnologue
catalogs all the living languages of the
world so here's like the page for
English you can learn lots of useful
facts about English and any other
language you want to know about I've
worked a lot with Wahls
which is the world atlas of language
structure on this is the online version
that's not in the acronym this is really
cool because it takes properties of
language so one we're gonna look at here
is like subject-object-verb order and
then it assigns every single language
like a value and so you basically can
download this like whole table of values
for all of these different languages on
all of these different properties and
that's really fun and that can help you
so here here's a for an example they
have like cool maps and stuff too which
are less useful for data analysis but
fun to look at so these are ancient
languages and this is like
subject-object-verb order so like if I
say John eats a cookie John is the
subject eats as the verb a cookie is the
object so in English right that's the
subject verb object
SVO but not all languages order them in
that order so different languages will
do different things they'll put the verb
first they'll put they'll put different
things first and so that's a difference
anyways I'm gonna leave it at that but
I'm just gonna say that language varies
a lot and that can mess up your
processing and so it's like worth being
aware of this and and recognizing how
this affects your processing okay last
lesson is that when you are using
pre-built tools I'm particularly gonna
focus here in like natural language
processing tools one they are not
available in all languages and that is
its own story - they do not work equally
well in all languages so you cannot just
assume that something out of the package
that works really nicely at English is
gonna work really nicely on the language
you care about and I want to talk really
briefly here about word embeddings which
is what my dissertation research is
around for those of you who don't know
what a word embedding is it's basically
a way of representing a word in a
computer so it's a vector representation
of a word you can kind of think about it
like a point in 300 dimensional space
and these are like much simplified so
this is like dumbed down to two
dimensions so I can like draw it on a
slide but here are points for these
different words and they capture some of
the meaning of the words so they capture
the usage of the word or the part of
speech or the word or other different
properties of the word so there are
different ways that you can measure kind
of the quality of a word embedding one
that I have done some work on is is this
definition called stability and this
kind of means if you take two embedding
spaces like from the same data and you
look at the the nearest neighbors for a
word so here's our two embedding spaces
these are all like points right in 300
dimensional space we're taking the same
word International in both languages and
we're looking at its ten nearest
neighbors in 300 dimensional space using
like cosine similarity or some other
like similarity function the stability
is how many of these neighbors overlap
so in this example four out of the ten
neighbors are the same so we're gonna
have 40 percent stability so this is
this is sort of a way to measure the the
quality of the word image maybe maybe
consistency is like a better word you
can kind of think about this as like as
like a way to measure consistency so one
way to think about this is what if you
had the same word embedding algorithm in
the same data but you ran it twice with
like two different random seeds or
something like that or on two different
subsets of the data like some kind of
trivial change that you think like
shouldn't really affect the structure
how consistent is your word embedding
across that and this is a way to sort of
measure that I'm happy to take questions
about this at the end if that didn't
make sense so but I will just say this
is kind of a metric of quality so if
that went over your head this is the
metric of quality leave it at that and
some of the research we've been doing
recently suggests that the quality is
very very different for different
languages so looking at our set of 38
languages we found that Vietnamese is
the most stable and it kind of has an
average stability of 23% jumping all the
way down to Lithuania and about 6% and
then English just for
of a reference point is around like 8%
which brings us back to the point that
not all tools work equally well in all
languages and that's something to be
aware of when processing multilingual
data um feel free to get in touch with
me thanks questions yes so it is it is
kind of a sense of like the embedding is
capturing the same thing so you
definitely normally don't do stability
across different languages kind of just
languages are so variable that it'd be
hard to get that to work methodological
each time so normally this is like these
these numbers right here yeah this is
stability within a language so we're not
going to cross languages we're going
within languages so we're looking at
just embeddings and Vietnamese how good
are they versus embeddings and only
lithuanian how good are they not
necessarily like going across language
but within a language it is a sense for
like if we're an if we had kind of two
Vietnamese embedding spaces on the same
data with the same algorithm like are
they consistent like do they have the
same nearest neighbors or are they
capturing like the same structure does
that help okay
justify the words in the languages how
did you compare so for these right here
so this is somewhat work in progress for
the results right here this is just like
word segmentation it's the open NLP
probabilistic word segment a seg segment
er for when that's available and if it's
not it's like it's called the Unicode
like a leucine algorithm and it's kind
of based on like Unicode I'm actually
really interested in the suburb stuff
and I think the next set of experiments
would be using something called sentence
peace p IE c e but also i mean that's
kind of something that's been pretty
heavily used in like machine translation
for solving this this exact same problem
yeah
different from the same walk
yeah that's a good way of doing it so in
this this experiment perhaps I should
have given a little more detail about
that sorry if that was unclear and we
used Wikipedia and we took Wikipedia and
all these languages and then we down
sampled Wikipedia because so the
Wikipedia's are all very different sizes
across different languages so we down
sampled Wikipedia to make it the same
size across all the languages but we did
multiple down samples so we like
selected 5,000 sentences from Vietnamese
once and then we selected another 5,000
sentences and now we've got two same
sized sets of Vietnamese Wikipedia we
can train to embedding spaces on that
and then we can compare them with in
Vietnamese kind of okay come come talk
to me later if you still have questions
about it I'm happy to explain it more
[Applause]